welcome back everyone
i am thrilled to be introducing our
final speaker for the evening the
excellent
michael knowles michael knowles is the
host of the michael knowles show
at the daily wire and co-host of the
chart topping podcast
verdict with ted cruz which will be
coming to campuses across the country
this fall
as part of yaf's campus lecture program
in 2017 michael wrote the number one
best-selling treatise reasons to vote
for democrats
a comprehensive guide which president
donald trump hailed as a great book for
your reading enjoyment
vanity fair has described michael as a
dapper lib-triggering troll
before blank book fame michael studied
history
and italian literature at yale
university
graduating with honors at yale michael
rendered the first ever translation for
the english stage of political
philosopher nicolo machiavelli's play
the girl from
andros which machiavelli scholar angelo
capodevaca hailed as a watershed event
for the english-speaking world
also in 2017 michael teamed up with
acclaimed
novelist and screenwriter andrew clavin
to perform the 13 episode narrative
podcast
another kingdom which garnered nearly 2
000
five star reviews by the release of its
final installment
rising to become one of the most popular
arts podcasts of the year
before being renewed for a second season
michael has appeared regularly on fox
and friends ewtn
news nightly and one america news
network's tipping point
among other television news programs
he has lectured at universities
throughout the united states
including the university of pennsylvania
michigan state university
yeshiva university franciscan university
of steubenville
most recently ave maria university and
and many others through yaf's logan
family lecture series
i know michael's remarks tonight will
leave you prepared and excited to bring
conservative ideas back to your
schools please help me welcome michael
knowles
all right thank you fabulous thank you
thank you so much i was very magnanimous
of claire to include the reference to
ave maria
university a rival school of hers
that she went to but lots of great
schools that we've been to thank you so
very much
thank you to yaf as always for hosting
thank you to the logan family for
sponsoring this lecture series
it is so good to be with all of you in
person
especially during these fraught bizarre
violent times that we are living through
no justice no peace
that is what we are told that is what
the leftist radicals who
spent much of last year burning our
country to the ground inform us
every time they go outside i am a little
skeptical
that peace is the top priority of the
looters and the arsonists and the
murderers who took to our streets last
year
i'm also doubtful that justice is a top
priority for them either
but they seem to think that what they
are after is justice
and who are we to tell them otherwise
this has been a crucial failure of the
right in recent decades
we refuse to answer this simple question
what is justice justice james madison
tells us in federalist 51
is the end of government always has been
always will be
okay what is justice
the left has a very simple answer to
this question justice to the left
is the opposite of whatever we think it
is
simple enough the left's conception of
justice
better known as political correctness or
wokism
is purely a negative vision that seeks
first to criticize and then to abolish
traditional standards this is why the
left is so hell-bent on abolishing the
police
the police are the physical
representation of
our justice system if the justice system
is rotten
if our conception of justice is rotten
then all the cops have to be rotten
too just this week after a police
officer saved a young girl's life
when another girl had a knife in her
hand and was inches away from
stabbing this other girl in the neck
now we are told that this cop is a
vicious racist vile murderer
as the girl drew the knife she screamed
quote i'm going to stab the blank out of
you
blank i'm going to clean up the language
for the kids at home
the girl whose life was saved as well as
a neighbor
went on the record to say the cops saved
lives the whole scene was captured on
video from multiple angles
and still prominent leftists attacked
the cop lebron james threatened
him on social media other blue check
leftists
came after the cop they insisted that
knife fighting
is simply a part of black youth culture
it's wrong they said for a white cop to
interfere
in a little friendly shanking between
friends
few people take a dimmer view of
leftists and celebrities than i do and
yet
that reaction surprised even me the libs
actually defended stabbing children
in order to maintain their their
position that no use of police force is
ever
justified so the lib position on justice
is clear it's the opposite of whatever
conservatives once said that it was
however to the libs credit at least they
have
a position what is the conservative
position on justice
little trickier to pin down these days
you rarely even hear conservatives talk
about justice
you will hear a lot of talk about
liberty although the definition of
liberty has gotten pretty fuzzy recently
too
you'll hear some talk about rights
equality
maybe even fairness very little talk
about
justice justice means
giving to each what he deserves it means
putting things in their proper order
in their proper place it is an habitual
inclination
of the will but in recent years
conservatives have refused to
acknowledge the existence of propriety
and order
they refuse to acknowledge that the will
ought to be inclined in any particular
direction at all
you do you some of these conservatives
will say
hey man just do whatever you want just
don't make me pay for it that's another
that's another line
they have embraced the language of the
libertines who hold that right and wrong
are no more than just like your opinion
man
to quote that great political
philosopher jeffrey the dude lebowski
conservatives have fallen into the
subtle trap
that the leftists have laid before them
in the form of political correctness
as we saw this week the left's goal is
simple
upend the traditional order in the words
of karl marx
to pursue the ruthless criticism of all
that exists
later marxists expounded upon this idea
through academic disciplines such as
critical theory and its more recent
derivation
critical race theory once you get past
all of the pretentious jargon in these
theories
the theory is very simple the theory is
to criticize
and it's a brilliant theory because in
this fallen world
everything just about is susceptible to
criticism
so the left wants to destroy the old
standards and it lays a trap for
conservatives whereby
no matter how we respond we advance
political correctness the first way that
conservatives react
is by giving in these are these are the
squishy types you know them
i won't name them but they're the ones
who say oh
it's not a big deal you know
cross-dressing radicals or twerking for
toddlers at the public library but
actually
drag queen story hour is one of the
blessings of liberty
there there are actual self-styled
conservatives who have said that
i won't name who they are but you all
know exactly what i'm talking about
if you listen very closely actually you
can hear james madison
turning in his grave when statements
like that are made
that group of conservatives obviously
gives the left what it wants because it
just gives in it just rolls over
the bad news is that even the
conservatives who appear to be resisting
political correctness
also help advance that radical ideology
as well
the second group of conservatives
refuses to go along with the latest woke
trends
but they do so on the grounds of free
speech
absolutism they won't accept the left's
new standards
but they they won't accept standards at
all and they they disavow all standards
what this latter group of conservatives
fails to understand
is that their reaction advances the
left's project just as surely as the
squishes do
because either way the traditional
standards are undermined
this is why for decades now no matter
how hard we fight against political
correctness
we always seem to lose ground
the left's victories seem to be
accelerating here we have gone from
barack obama and hillary clinton
asserting that marriage is a sacred bond
between a man and a woman
two if you don't castrate your kids
you're a bigot
in about eight years that is not an
exaggeration
the reason is that we have failed to
recognize that political correctness
does not represent a battle
between free speech and censorship
rather it is a battle
between competing sets of standards or
more specifically
the traditional standards and the
anti-standard of the left
it is in other words the ruthless
criticism of all that exists
where once our politics rested on a
culture formed by christianity
now our politics derives from the state
established church of secular
progressivism
whereas once we encouraged virtue and
discouraged vice
today the left has transformed the seven
deadly sins
into the perverse virtues of
progressivism
saints gregory the great and thomas
aquinas once called pride the queen of
all vices
my friend andrew clavin has pointed out
that it has become the vice of all
queens
i find this to be a very politically
incorrect phrase i would never
i would never say that but he said that
so i'll repeat it for you
in the christian liturgy we acknowledge
our own sinfulness by striking our
breasts and chanting
through my fault through my fault
through my most grievous fault i have
greatly sinned
lord i am not worthy that you should
enter under my roof
in the liberal liturgy we strike our
breasts and we repeat
black lives matter black lives matter we
acknowledge our white privilege
and we we acknowledge the white
supremacy that allegedly governs our
country
we are told that a filthy little piece
of cloth will protect us from a
contagious
and microscopic virus christians wear
mantillas
secular progressives wear the masks we
genuflect at the altar of public health
which reverses its proclamations by the
hour
can those two faiths get along together
can a faithful christian be a leftist of
this sort
no no simply not the church has been
very clear on this issue for for
starters
it is not permissible for a christian to
support a pro-abortion
politician in elections such as the ones
we've recently seen
it is not permissible for a faithful
christian to support socialism which has
been condemned
as quote a pest a plague
a wicked confederacy that seeks to steal
the very gospel itself
by pope leo xiii also condemned by
blessed pope pius ix pope saint pius the
10th pope benedict xv
pope pius xi pope pius xii pope john
xxiii who was actually relatively
liberal
and who said quote no catholic could
subscribe
even to a moderate form of socialism
you get the point we could we could name
other popes but i think the church has
been clear on this point
leftism woke-ism is contrary to the
christian faith
its values are the opposite of our
values which
brings us back to pride what is pride
pride is the excessive love of one's own
excellence
it is what caused satan to fall like
lightning from heaven
it is what caused adam to fall from the
garden of eden pride
is a fantasy there's a fantasy that you
are perfect
just the way you are conservatives
understand this
leftists do not it is one of the major
distinctions between the right and the
left
the left believes that human nature is
perfectable
woodrow wilson and the other founders of
american progressivism put it in
precisely those terms
whereas the constitution was written in
the old age of isaac newton where we had
fixed laws
and eternal truths in the universe
that's over that's bunk
we're now living in the age of charles
darwin nothing is fixed
everything is evolving baby and we're
all going to evolve toward
progress in this world we can finally
remake mankind
eradicate poverty eradicate suffering
eradicate evil and sin
barack obama promised to quote heal the
planet
aoc promises to quote save
the world left-wing politicians since
john f kennedy have summed up this view
they have said this is a direct quote
from president kennedy
some people see things that are and say
why i dream things that never were and
say
why not it's one of the most famous
lines in american political history
it is a quote as kennedy acknowledged
from the socialist playwright george
bernard shaw
kennedy was very very fond of quoting
great writers but not actually reading
their works
so ken he did this to dante too so
kennedy knew that shaw wrote the line
what he didn't know though is that the
line comes from shaw's
play cycle back to methuselah and
actually the line is
in the mouth of the serpent in the
garden of eden tempting eve
they are the words of the devil he says
i have this very inspiring view of life
it comes from oh satan yes satan's view
okay
pure pride if the default political
position of the left is pride the
default political mode of conservatives
is the opposite it's humility
the conservative view of politics is
essentially
humble we do not think that we can
radically remake mankind
we do not think that we can
fundamentally transform america and we
would not want to fundamentally
transform america
even if we could why because we love
america
you don't fundamentally transform things
that you love
say that to your sweetheart i want to
fundamentally transform you see
how she reacts as michael oakshott put
it
quote to be conservative then is to
prefer the familiar to the unknown
to prefer the tried to the untried fact
to mystery
the actual to the possible the limited
to the unbounded
the near to the distant the sufficient
to the super abundant
the convenient to the perfect present
laughter
to utopian bliss love that
the left approach is politics from the
perspective of pride
conservatives from the perspective of
humility
the rest of the political virtues and
vices flow from there
the seven deadly sins i'm in a room full
of good
well-educated catholic students who can
tell me the seven deadly sins
oh it's not good not many people there's
one back there yes
nailed it that was great excellent
excellent the rest of you need to study
up on your catechism
on your catholic writing it's very
important because it really gets to the
heart of our politics
for those who couldn't hear in the back
of the room pride envy wrath sloth greed
gluttony and lust have you ever heard a
more
concise description of leftism than that
no
probably not leftism is envy
winston churchill described it he
described socialism rather
as the philosophy of failure the creed
of ignorance
and the gospel of envy leftism
is all envy and the leftists pretend
that it is kindness
the left actually tries to convince
people that if you want to keep your own
money that that is greed
but when you covet and steal somebody
else's money that is kindness
new york's bolshevik mayor mr bill de
blasio
launched his ill-fated presidential run
by saying quote
there's plenty of money in this country
it's just in the wrong hands
whose hands should it be in bill well i
think his answer would be it should be
in his hands
and then he could use all that money
however he wants sitting at the helm of
the government
a lot of people confuse envy and greed
but they are different
envy doesn't make you want something for
its own sake
it makes you want something simply so
that someone else
doesn't have it totally negative
conservatives i think in recent decades
have focused too much on tax cuts
seems to be the only thing that
conservatives can ever agree to do when
they actually have political power and
that's too bad they need to do a lot of
other things
however they do have a point on the tax
cuts
because the rich pay a lot of taxes
in this country the rich pay almost all
of the taxes in this country
in 2016 the top three percent of u.s
taxpayers paid the majority
of the taxes the top one percent of
income earners paid more than the bottom
90 percent combined
the top 50 percent paid 97 percent of
total
individual income taxes so what do we
want
we do we want them to pay 98 yeah
that'll satisfy everybody
no have at 99 then we're all good then
no of course not
the left doesn't care what the effect of
those taxes would be
they don't even really care where the
money goes they just want to make sure
that some people don't get to keep it
how about wrath
just this past week maxine waters called
for riots
if the derek chovin jury did not give
her preposterous
give her the preposterous verdict that
she wanted
she said that leftists need to take to
the streets
and become more confrontational
they had just spent six months looting
rioting burning down the country not
confrontational enough for maxine waters
what is what is more confrontational
they would have to set off a nuclear
weapon
to be more confrontational but maxine is
not new to this sort of thing
few years ago she encouraged a mob of
her supporters to attack
conservatives in public wherever they
saw them to quote
get in their faces to go to their homes
where their children sleep
to harass them and it's not just maxine
waters
she's a little flamboyant about these
calls for violence
others do it as well our sitting vice
president kamala harris
kamala harris raised money to bail out
the minnesota rioters
remember last year minnesota goes up in
flames
what would a responsible politician do
hey be peaceful don't do that no what is
what is what does kamala harris do she
goes and raises money for them as did
staffers for joe biden despite all of
the pearl clutching over
right-wing insurrectionists sort of
people who put on horn helmets and
danced around the capital on on desks
and things like that
the mainstream left actively encouraged
a largely successful insurrection last
year
mainstream leftists in high positions of
power many of them continue to do it
today
about sloth well sloth goes along with
envy
the left wants to get something for
nothing it wants to profit off of other
people's work
to enjoy professional and social
benefits without the labor and the cost
america is a land of opportunity we
offer the widest
opportunity for the greatest number of
people regardless of birth or
circumstance
to accumulate wealth pursue their
desires in the history of the world
if you can't make it here you can't make
it anywhere
and yet the left seeks as best it can
to come up with excuses for not
achieving
someone else is privileged
the system is out to get them someone
else is keeping them down
ironically grievance and victimhood have
become privileges to the left
everyone wants to be able to claim some
sort of oppression
i do it i don't i can't tell if i i'm a
little swarthy because i'm sicilian
i don't know if i can make a credible
claim to any sort of grievance but in
the future if we want to have any
privileges at all
our politics seems to be reduced to
these very silly and superficial points
ultimately all of this is just an excuse
for laziness
because in the long haul in the united
states if you are willing to work hard
anyone and everyone can improve his lot
in life
how about greed greed is the selfish
desire for the thing itself
everybody can be greedy but studies show
that leftists are greedier than
conservatives
you know how much i love studies i do i
really i think studies are basically all
fake
but i will cite them when they suit my
opinions so that is that's what i'm
doing here
the new york times actually had to admit
this a few years ago after investigating
irs data why are leftists
so stingy why do conservatives give more
to charity more often than the left
it's because they outsource their
charity to other people through the
government
but when you outsource your charity you
destroy a charity
the socialist senator bernie sanders has
made his stinginess a point of pride
in 1981 he told the new york times i
don't believe in charities
preferring instead a government takeover
of almsgiving
the ex-communist whitaker chambers whose
book witness helped to make ronald
reagan a conservative
recounted the experience of meeting a
beggar in new york's bowery neighborhood
chambers was walking around he says a
shivering derelict came up to us
and asked for a handout harry his
communist friend
glanced past him which was the proper
communist attitude
communists hold that to give alms is to
dull
the revolutionary spirit of the masses
when chambers gave the beggar some coins
his friend reprimanded him he said you
must not
think about them even though he himself
was was moved with pity
despite this natural sympathy chambers
understood that quote
from the communist position he was right
and i was wrong
the old standards impelled chambers to
answer the beggar's plea
but the new leftist standards cared too
much for humanity
to care very much about any individual
humans
how about gluttony the left has a
rapacious appetite
not always for food but for property for
rights
mostly for institutions and traditions
the left's desire here is not to edify
but to consume
the opposite of gluttony is the virtue
of temperance which conservatives keep
at the forefront of our minds when we
think about society in general
and government in particular then there
is lust
if recent news stories highlighting the
left sexualization of children in
particular
drag kids dollar bills thrown at dancing
children that sort of thing you see in
the headlines all the time now
if that has not convinced you of this
fact then you can find the roots of this
bizarre obsession with sex in the
strange writings of bernie sanders he
wrote these
crazy treatises about sex in the 60s and
70s
you can find it in the creepy theories
of perverts like wilhelm reich
a very influential left-wing theorist
who held that all of the problems of
this world
sickness disease social discord were
actually caused i kid you not
by people having too few orgasms this
there
this was parodied in a woody allen movie
uh where he talked about the orgasmatron
this was a big wooden box where
who knows what people did in there the
this leftist theory
had a lot of sway over people like
norman mailer people like jd salinger
people like bernie sanders
now they downplay it but this creepy
creepy obsession with sex has been on
the left for a long time
the left wields lust and sex as a
political tool because it knows that sex
sells lust is incredibly powerful
pop culture likes to pretend that the
left embraces the sexual revolution
that the left is sex positive because it
is just simply
cooler and hipper than conservatives who
are we're prudish old fuddy-duddies
aren't we
this is a catholic conference i suspect
some of you come from
large families i i would imagine you
know
firsthand the the catholics and the
conservatives are not uh
sex negative they're not prudes but they
recognize that sex is a very powerful
thing
what the left wants to do is take us
away from our senses
enslave us to our appetites and keep us
focused on our most primal desires
while the activists reshape our politics
and culture the depravity
never ends the left mocks conservatives
for making slippery slope arguments
they'll say you know you heard these
arguments for a while right if we
redefine marriage pretty soon there will
be a push to legalize polygamy
if we normalize deviant sexual behaviors
pretty soon we'll normalize pedophilia
if we normalize hardcore porn and casual
sex pretty soon women will be degraded
the trouble with the left's criticism of
these slippery slope arguments
is that the conservatives were right
about every single point
it's happened even more quickly than
many conservatives said that it would
what began with playboy has ended with
whap
what started as free love has ended with
movies like cuties
conservatives favor chastity not because
we underestimate sex
not because we never stumble when we try
to live up to it
but precisely because we understand the
power of sex we understand how central
sex is to our humanity how powerful a
passion sexual desire can be
how strong a motivator it is for human
action
lust gluttony greed sloth wrath envy
and pride the seven deadly sins the
seven virtues
of leftism all the necessary ingredients
to destroy a soul and a nation
our founding fathers knew that if our
nation were to survive
it would require an immense amount of
virtue
george washington wrote virtue is a
necessary spring of popular government
without virtue happiness cannot be
rights thomas jefferson
at the outset of the constitutional
convention benjamin franklin wrote
only a virtuous people are capable of
freedom as nations become
more corrupt and vicious they have more
need of masters
our founding fathers did not write do
whatever you want you know
you do you do whatever feels good no
they said that our entire form of
government
requires the cultivation of virtue in
our citizens
when the left chance no justice no peace
they have a point they're they're making
a threat
but they're also making an observation
about politics and the world
a nation that disregards or even inverts
justice
will not have peace just as our founding
fathers warned us
let us therefore favor true religion
over false
and a politics of virtue over vice
chastity temperance charity diligence
patience
kindness humility those virtues do not
strut around in parades
but they offer the only hope of building
a nation worthy of really being proud
thank you very much
thank you okay guys you know the drill
questions are over there line up at the
microphone
hello my name is katrina i go to the
catholic university of america
um i usually don't ask controversial
questions at yale conferences but here
it goes i bring that out
yeah um so i know that you oppose
the official catholic church position on
the death penalty
um i don't think i do but okay well
yeah um so i'm against the death penalty
as
i think that is the current position of
the catholic church
um as um pope john paul ii also
um has some great wisdom on that topic
so i was just wondering if you could
talk about that for a little bit
pope said john paul ii never said that
it is
uh somehow wrong for a catholic to
to support the death penalty neither did
pope benedict the 16th
the confusion has arisen here because of
a change in the language in the
catechism
by pope francis but you'll notice even
the language that pope francis used was
very very particular
he stopped short of saying that capital
punishment is intrinsically evil
he can't say that capital punishment is
intrinsically evil because
it is defended not just by the great
saints and doctors of the church
it not only because it was practiced by
great popes
some of whom have been beatified i'm
thinking of pope blessed pope pius ix
who took care of a fair fair share of
criminals
with capital punishment in the papal
states but it's also defended explicitly
in the bible it's defended explicitly
in the writings of saint paul among
other places so the church can never
say that it is at all times always
intrinsically evil to pursue capital
punishment
now there there were some statements
made by pope saint john paul ii
who said that as a prudential matter
really capital punishment should not be
carried out
all that often but you know it's still
legitimate and pope benedict xvi
i think put it very well and very
diplomatically and very clearly which
unfortunately there seems to be a lack
of clarity often in this pontificate
but benedict put it very clearly when he
said that catholics can have a
legitimate difference of opinion
on the matter of capital punishment i
support capital punishment
along with blessed pope pius ix i've
never carried one out like he did but
i support it because i think we've lost
a real sense of justice
your question is excellent because it
gets to the heart of our topic tonight
what is justice and what do we mean by a
criminal justice system
there are three purposes of criminal
justice
rehabilitation that's the one we talk
about all the time now deterrence that's
another one
and retribution retribution and that's
not just like a kind of old-fashioned
you know third one that maybe we should
forget about it that's the primary
purpose
if rehabilitation is the primary purpose
of criminal
justice then we should all go to jail at
some point right i've got plenty of
habits that i could use some
rehabilitation on
i think we all do if deterrence were the
primary purpose of criminal justice
then it doesn't matter if the person
that we're punishing is guilty or not
we're just trying to make an example of
somebody right we're just trying to
deter other people from committing a
crime
retribution that is the primary purpose
we heard
we are punishing people because they
have offended justice because they've
committed the crime
and i i don't see any reason to believe
that
this means we can give them a parking
ticket you know but we can't possibly
enact capital punishment
capital punishment is cruel and unusual
certainly not by the standards of the
constitution
the definition of a felony was capital
punishment at the time of ratification
so i don't think our founders meant that
you might say that that life
imprisonment would be cruel and unusual
punishment certainly by the lights of
the constitution
so i think there's a good argument to
abolish life in prison and replace it
with
a swifter death penalty process i think
there's a good argument to be made
that the death penalty is unevenly
carried out
very rarely carried out at all people
languishing on death row for 30 years i
don't think that's particularly just
but i i don't think that the state holds
the sword in vain
to get back to the biblical basis of
some of these issues
and i i also would say
that while the retributive effect and
the deterrent effect of capital
punishment are well established
despite some popular protestations to
the contrary
few people acknowledge the
rehabilitative effects of capital
punishment
a little bit of a morbid business here
but it actually can have quite a
rehabilitative effect a quote dr johnson
hanging concentrates the mind what i
mean by that is
his full quote is when a man knows he is
to be hanged in a fortnight
depend upon it sir it concentrates his
mind wonderfully and if the real purpose
of justice here
is to bring this person's soul back into
order really to rehabilitate it
a man might languish on death row for 30
40 years
no end in sight he might die of some
disease later on
never come face to face with this
question of justice but when he's facing
the scaffold he very well will
and so certainly it would seem to me in
my humble opinion
and the humble opinion of the greatest
doctors of the church and of the
scripture
that capital punishment is justified but
i think there's a
pressing social aspect to it here a
pressing political aspect
and i think it is compassionate for the
very people who would suffer it
great thank you excellent question
hi mr knowles i'm nick i'm from auburn
university i've heard of that place
oh yeah it's it's it's a nice place um
so we know like in history there have
been times where the catholics have been
on top you know like in control of the
culture
a big like movement in the culture and
then there are also been times where
we've been
like where we've been greatly persecuted
and had to kind of like draw back
so do you think that our culture is like
salvageable like is this a time where we
should kind of like draw back and kind
of like
solidify our beliefs and like preserve
what we have and just like wait for rome
to fall
you know like to wait for it or is this
a time where we should try to
like come back and take back this
culture of ours
courage is a virtue we forget that often
courage is actually the prerequisite of
all the other virtues
and i think that uh a lot of
conservatives and catholics in
particular
might want to say hey actually it's
better in the long run if i retreat to
my beach house and
raise my family right and not not deal
with politics anymore
but that's not what i would do i i'm i'm
not willing to give up on the country
uh you know my i love my country like i
love my family love of country is an
extension of filial piety
and i don't think the culture is so
totally lost that
at this point we're just waiting to be
fed to the lions or something like that
it's true that now especially after 2020
religiosity is really cratered in
america i think fewer than 50
of of americans go to church of any sort
of practice religion really of any
of any solid kind there are a whole lot
of spiritual but not religious types but
in terms of
rigorous religion it's really dropping
but i think we can take that back and i
think part of the reason that we've lost
it by the way
is that this issue of cowardice many
catholics
christians more broadly and
conservatives have refused to assert
a substantive moral vision of politics
so what we've done
is seed ground again and again and again
and say well you know look i who knows
if drag queen story hour if i
look man if i tell you that that you
can't twerk for kids at the library
then you might tell me that i can't go
to church and by the way
they're already telling us we can't go
to church they're not letting us do that
they closed churches for all of last
year so i think there's nothing really
to lose in the hypothetical here
but also if we cannot discern between
right wrong and good and bad in drag
queen story hour and going to church on
sunday
then we do not possess the faculties of
reason and the moral conscience which is
a judgment of reason that is essential
to self-government
self-government is predicated on the
idea that we can discern between good
and bad and right and wrong true and
false
so i i'm not willing to seed the culture
at all
and i think actually the reason we've
gotten to this
low point that we're at is because we've
been practicing that run for the hills
option
for i don't know 30 years at this point
i'm i'm humbly suggesting
before we give it all in and jump into
the mouth of the lions
and we recognize that the whole time
suffering is sanctifying anyway
but before we totally give up hope and
despair is a sin
we we might try you know fighting back a
little
my humble suggestion yeah so thank you
thank you
um hi my name is lily i go to [ __ ] your
high school and this doesn't really have
to do with your talk
but in school we're taught that there
was a
switch of the political parties
especially with like the slavery
argument
and then i brought it up with my dad and
he had like no clue what i was talking
about so is that real that we like
switched parties and that were
like republicans are actually like the
old slaveholders compared to like
abraham lincoln being uh like a
republican but in reality he's a
democrat like
yeah you don't remember that you don't
remember how i think it was
governor you can remind me you're a much
better student of history than i am
i think it was december 2nd 1963
all the democrats and the republicans
got together right they sat down and
they said okay from now on
you're going to be the democrats and
we're going to be the
is that that's something roughly what
happened yeah okay i couldn't quite
remember the dates
um that's right
that's true that's true that's right the
republican party
began beginning with lincoln that would
be wouldn't that be crazy the first
republican president
is actually just secretly a democrat uh
no that didn't really happen
now what is the point that they're
trying to make
different states have gone democrat and
republican at different times different
groups of people have switched parties
or some gravitation
the parties have gone more their
democratic party became much more
radically leftist especially in the 60s
and different parties changed their
views on certain policies the republican
party was protectionist when it was
founded and then it became more free
trade and now it's a little bit more
protectionist again yeah okay fine right
of course
of course political parties change their
policies with the changing circumstances
but the idea that the party's
fundamentally switched and that the dems
get to claim
abraham lincoln is i think wish-casting
in history
it has no bearing on truth and the
reason that they do it of course
is that the democratic party has a
really really vile history
they've defended some of the worst
things and they continue to defend the
worst things
and when this country wakes up and
realizes the moral horror of abortion
and the idea that we kill a million
babies a year and democrats are cheering
it on
andrew cuomo lighting up buildings to
celebrate the
the killing of babies up up until the
point of birth
when they realize that that is certainly
at least
as horrifying as any practice of slavery
then you know what they're going to do
in
50 or 60 years they're going to say it's
switched again and then oh yeah actually
it was in yeah sometime in 2023 all the
parties switched again
and actually the republicans loved
abortion give me a break ridiculous
thank you thank you
hello um i'm catalina i attend oak crest
school here in vienna
and so kind of going off of your
comments earlier on courage and
cowardice
i've been pretty disappointed in what i
see as like somewhat of a conservative
failure to effectively use political
power
when we do have it so i was going to ask
what you think we should do going
forward on how we can sort of
effectively and really encourage our
conservative principles
i want to elect you to something you
have totally the right idea i'm so
pleased to hear you say that the
the refusal of republicans to wield
political power and fight back
is is one of the most depressing aspects
of our politics
i actually i don't say this just to
flatter governor walker because he's in
the room here
but you know you really faced a serious
fight and you you actually fight back
and
look at what you got for it you know you
get recalled they're threatening you
they fight you
because there are very few republican
politicians who are ever willing to do
that
what do most republican politicians do
well you know
guys let's we can't fight this battle
today
because you know we got other priorities
and so we'll get it next time
keep giving us your checks by the way
keep giving us your votes but no we're
not going to push back on the unions
we're not going to push back on abortion
we're not going to push back on
anything next time next time next time
and some of them the the
the most ridiculous sophists of of all
of them will try to defend this and
they'll say hey guys come on
we can't that'd be if we wielded
political power
why that would make us know better than
the democrats
because you know democrats wield
political power
uh yeah right they're in politics yeah
if we drank water
that would make us know better than the
democrat the democrats drink water yeah
right that's not the problem the right
the problem is
how the democrats are wielding political
power
i i think that the lack of a substantive
moral vision is a problem
part of the challenge for this of course
is that the gop and the conservative
coalition more broadly is made up of
disparate groups
so you've got these groups just off the
top of my head the traditional
conservatives the libertarians
the warhawk former democrats you might
call them the neoconservatives the
populists the this the that and the
other thing
right they have very diverging views
and so the one thing they agreed on for
a while was tax cuts
but they didn't all agree on the other
aspects so it's hard to wrangle it's
like wrangling a herd of cats
they would make themselves feel better
by saying
hey don't worry about it it was you
couldn't do it anyway because you can't
legislate morality you ever hear that
one
you can't legislate morality what does
that even mean you
all laws legislate morality every
the whole idea of a law is that you
realize something is true or false or
good or bad
and then you pass the law and then
people have to follow that moral vision
that's true that's true of capital
punishment that's true of abortion
that's true of parking tickets that's
true of
everything and it's just an excuse so
that politicians can keep cashing their
donation checks and keep
sitting in their fancy offices and not
actually do anything because they know
that
when you fight back the left goes after
you but yeah my my view is that
if if we don't boot out those squishy
weak
selfish cowardly craven how many other
adjectives can i use
republicans then we have no hope give me
an honest leftist
he at least gives a vision for the
country it's a wicked vision i hate the
vision
but at least he's doing something the
guy's got courage at least
where is that where is that on the right
few and far between
in politicians and so when you can find
it in a certain politician
i would i would encourage it thank you
hello again i'm emma raymond and i'm
from our lady of mercy in rochester new
york
and thank you for your speech first but
i asked a
similar question earlier but i'd love to
hear your opinion on it a lot of people
today especially
atheists tend to idolize some
politicians and they believe that
they're in their best interests they're
very charming with their promises
how do you say that we would convince
them to do otherwise to look and within
themselves to advocate for them
so can you state the first part of your
question again what what the left is
doing
yeah so a lot of people today like
atheists and just
young people tend to idolize uh
politicians like like the squad and they
look to them for
advocacy and advice and they believe
that they have their best interests so
what could we do to deter them
the issue i think gets back to the
nature of liberty
right the reason that people will rely
on politicians for every single thing
and for their self-worth and for
rigging the system in favor of one
interest group against another
is because they're not really free
people
they haven't cultivated their higher
intellect and their higher will
they haven't tamped down their vices
they cannot do for themselves they
cannot earn from themselves they can't
control themselves
they can't really do anything they're
really pretty weak
and i think unfortunately on the right
we have
been part of this problem because we
have adopted the modern left's
definition of liberty to it to at least
a certain degree
the the modern liberal understanding of
liberty is that liberty is just doing
whatever you want the clearest example
of this would be a heroin addict
a heroin addict according to this
definition is the freest person in the
world
because he gets to go shoot up hero he's
got a buck in his pocket he can go shoot
up heroin
right he's pursuing his desires right
isn't that free
no everybody in this room knows that a
heroin addict is not free a heroin
addict is the least free person around
he's a slave
a slave to his lower appetites because
liberty and licentiousness as our
founding fathers robotic rate length
are not the same thing not only are they
not the same thing
they're polar opposites licentiousness
totally undermines liberty
and so if you've got a country full of
heroin addicts which is kind of
well literally it is what we have
because we have an opioid crisis but we
we have
even more broadly across other vices a
country full of heroin addicts
who are caught up in the and totally
encouraged by the politics and the
culture
to give into their most base crass
desires i i noticed this
most obviously with the ubiquity of
internet porn you'll notice that the
people who are calling
to regulate or outright ban internet
porn
it's not old fuddy duddies it's not the
old church lady
many times the boomer conservatives are
the ones defending internet porn it's
actually the younger gen z conservatives
usually the men
who are saying we gotta regulate this
stuff man why because they're dealing
with the effects of it because it is
actually compromising their lives
and their higher will and they don't
want to be trapped by that anymore
and it is simply the case getting back
to what our founding fathers said about
a
virtuous nation self-government only
befits
a virtuous nation if you've got a nation
of heroin addicts
it doesn't matter how beautifully
written your constitution is it doesn't
matter how shiny the marble is on the
supreme court building
you will not have a good government you
will not have a good society you will
not have peace
no justice no peace and so i think
cultivating the sense of sin is very
important here
to bring it back to the kind of catholic
aspect of this conference
when the the communion lines are long
and the confession lines are short
your culture has lost the sense of sin
and now what the left does is actually
tries to
exalt sin as a great virtue right so you
no longer do you want abortion to be
safe and legal and rare
now you want to shout your abortion from
the rooftops you have to affirm it as a
positive good
you no longer can you say hey you know
that girl had a
had a rough night you know went out with
that guy and now we all like that guy
and she
did things she shouldn't have done
anyway we move on no now it's
there are [ __ ] parades there's an actual
thing like go
shout your whatever this is true of all
manner of
vice the lady doth protest too much me
thanks on these i don't think when
people are shouting their abortions
they're doing so because they're filled
with joy
okay uh i think that if we were to
cultivate the sense of sin one it would
bring people back to humility which is
an essential
essential quality in conservative
government but
it would also wake people up to the
severity of the problem
and i think you know we ask too much of
our forebears
we i love ronald reagan very few people
love ronald reagan more than i do
governor walker maybe he is definitely
tied or
you know but we all look we all love
ronald reagan in this room
ronald reagan ain't going to fix this
the guy fixed his problems the guy won
the cold war
let him rest don't you don't have to dig
him out of the grave okay
william f buckley i love william f
buckley come on man give the guy a break
you can't blame him for everything and
you can't demand that he fix your
country and
ultimately of course the founding
fathers some of the greatest most
virtuous men who've ever walked the
earth
they did their part they gave us a great
country
we are the ones squandering that and you
can't blame them and you can't say well
you know they but they should have
written
this differently in the constitution
well reagan should have done this
differently but now i bet you'd do it
how about that how about you
to quote that great political
philosopher michael jackson
take a look at the man in the mirror and
start asking him to change his ways
great question
thank you
[Applause]
uh hi mr knowles uh my name is uh tim
wade i'm from colby academy
online school and i had a question for
you it's a do you so did you support or
what's your opinion of the stimulus
checks that went out to
americans in various rounds yeah which
ones
i guess is the real question i i think
that it is perfectly
right if the government shuts down the
country and tells people that they can't
go to work
and tells them they can't earn a living
and cracks the whole thing and shuts
your business down
then i think the government actually has
a responsibility to give you some money
but this is a very dangerous situation
first of all does anyone really believe
that
what was it twelve hundred dollars or
something that's good you shut down your
life for a year
but hey don't worry twelve hundred
dollars you can live on that can't you
cuban peasants can't live on twelve
hundred dollars in the streets of havana
a country that's been hollowed out by
communism for 60 years
you think that that's going to get you
very far in america i don't think so
it was to me a pittance it was crumbs i
actually i
had great sympathy for the conservative
argument that the stimulus checks
should have been higher but the problem
is there's no number that would ever be
enough
the real issue here is that they shut
down the country so i think the
the failure on the part of conservatives
too is
allowing themselves to be rolled by the
left is the country should never have
been shut down we should never have
outsourced our government to that little
guy with the funny accent in the lab
coat we shouldn't have done it
i did not elect anthony fauci to
anything
he's been there forever the guy was
serving in the jefferson administration
how did he amass that kind of power
that's that's a structural problem and
so
look you pass the checks and it's a
thousand dollars or whatever
okay or you don't like okay that to me
that is such a sideshow from the real
problem which is the total outsourcing
of our government
to people who i don't think really have
our best interests at heart and even if
they did are so totally incompetent
and so deeply stupid and ignorant of of
political philosophy
and the american tradition and so
indifferent to the american way of life
that uh that you know you make the check
ten thousand dollars who cares
the real problem is going to be
structural thank you very much
hi mr knowles um i'm lauren i'm a huge
fan thanks so much
and i was just wondering on your thought
um your thoughts on the idea that
considering the fact that like nowadays
the government
isn't really controlled by the people we
elect it's been outsourced to like
administrative offices and considering
the fact that
the executive branch and the head of our
country basically
there's much evidence to suggest that it
was stolen from us
and really nobody has been held
accountable for this
and so it seems like the people don't
really wield much political power
nowadays
so i was um wondering like what do you
think we should
like do if if we don't really have much
political power what should the american
people do
to improve their lives basically
improve the country we should take it
back i think you're right
obviously we've outsourced so much of
our government to the administrative
state
i got to meet the late justice scalia
twice actually before he died
i wouldn't have met him after he died
that would be very good
i got to meet him as a student twice and
we asked him what the greatest threat
was to the country and he said
the growth of the administrative state
the growth of the unelected executive
agencies
headless godless totally without any
accountability to the people
and that is a big problem the problem of
course is that the administrative state
didn't just spring out of thin air
it was developed through legal processes
mostly legal processes
in the country it's been around for
almost 100 years now
the architect of it was woodrow wilson
the implementer of it really was
franklin roosevelt it's going to be very
hard to unearth it
i don't think and i actually wouldn't
even support a candidate who said i'm
going to go in and i'm just going to
delete the administrative state just
boop you know there we go where is it on
highlight
administrative state it's gone you can't
you couldn't do it that would be such
a radical change to our government i i
don't think it'd be workable
and i'm not for revolution i am for
evolution
not revolution i i think that edmund
burke has a great deal of wisdom on this
point that we want
gradual change we want to take the best
of what we
had and then move forward you know you
cannot live
in the past no one would want to even if
you could
we might think when would you like to
live i think the country was the best in
1921 yeah that was that no maybe 1883
no no that's not really true you you
need to
uh be able to take what is best from
that tradition so i would look in and
i might delete whole agencies but i
wouldn't i wouldn't delete the whole
thing right away how can we do that
it's very hard the left has such an
advantage because the electeds come and
go
but the left runs the bureaucracy so it
doesn't matter you know you elect trump
or whoever
he's not going to have a whole lot of
sway there
however you can do it gradually you can
do it with great determination
and you can do it by wielding political
power
the right has not wanted to do that
they've promised to do that and they
don't do it
i suppose we'll need to have a candidate
who is who's
willing to wield that political power
and knows how to do it
usually we have candidates who don't
fall into either camp
with trump i think we had a candidate
who did want to do it
to a considerable degree but was not
able to do it he didn't have a really
totally functioning administration
because very few people wanted to work
for him
the entire establishment was against him
and so he he failed in many
regards he succeeded on a whole lot of
things but with the administrative state
could have been a lot better if you got
a politician in there
who was very skilled in the machinations
of government
and determined this would be a rare
thing in the gop to actually
do what they say they're going to do
then i think you could do it it wouldn't
all happen at once you'd have to be dog
you'd have to be determined you couldn't
be demoralized when four years later it
wasn't all gone you would need to take
the gradual insistence of the left that
they have used now for 100 years at the
very least
to wage what the communist theorist
antonio gramsci called a war of position
take positions of influence within
not just the government but in all of
the cultural institutions and then
finally wield that that influence right
now so much of what the left is doing is
deeply unpopular
the open borders right now the crisis at
the border the
radical sexual theories you know the the
transgender
children practices deeply deeply
unpopular
and yet they get away with it why
because they have positions of power and
influence
it's not a it's not a dirty and
nefarious thing to
take over institutions and wield
political power but the right has to be
willing to do it and smart enough to
accomplish it
yeah i'd just like to say that you're
the one who educated me on the
administrative
state so thank you for that oh that's so
kind thank you so much you know a great
book on that topic if you're interested
is unmasking the administrative state by
john marini
claremont institute highly recommended
reading if you're interested in the
topic all right well thank you for the
suggestion and thank you for talking
thank you
good evening mr knowles thank you so
much for this
great speech um i was just wondering as
a even though i'm not catholic as a
christian who shares many of the same
beliefs that you do
it's really hard watching people form
their opinions and their morals solely
based off of the media
and as someone who wants to go into
journalism
what is some of the best
ideas and changes that you think that
the media
mass media and journalists as a whole
can make
in order to help the country form their
own opinions
and support opinions instead of creating
them for them
if you want to go into mainstream
establishment journalism the first thing
i would recommend you do
is run to the back of the room and
destroy those cameras i would i would
take a hammer to them
because the minute that your face is
seen at one of these events you're dead
you're out they're not going to let you
in if you are going to be in more
independent-minded journalism or
conservative journalism or something
then you might be okay but i
i think you might want to go about it a
little differently than you've suggested
what you've said is you hate the idea
that the media are giving people their
opinions
you would prefer if people came to their
own opinions
the media will always give people their
opinions that is
necessary educators will always give
people their opinions i think
conservatives fall into a trap when we
say things like
you know we want education not
indoctrination
those words are synonyms they mean
exactly the same thing
we want to teach students how to think
not what to think you can't know
how to think unless you know what to
think you can't know how to think about
advanced calculus
if you don't know that two plus two
equals four
when a teacher when a teacher tells you
that uh the
revolutionary war began you know
independence day 1776
they're teaching you what to think right
and we would all support that you need
to know if you want to know facts dates
places that's
you need to know what to think and then
from there you can build up i think the
problem is
not that the media or educators or
whoever
are telling people what to think it's
what they are telling them to think
now does this mean that i think that
conservatives should just sort of
plug in you know and only watch one show
ever
yes you should only watch the michael
knowles show
but but if you're not going to do that
no i don't i don't think you should
necessarily only you know just become an
automaton and just regurgitate whatever
somebody tells you
you should take things in from various
sources
how can we do that in a responsible and
just way
you need to own your views so
when lester holt goes on nbc news just
this week and says there's
there was a shooting in in columbus ohio
and the officials say that the girl who
was shot the girl who was totally
innocent
she they say that she was holding a
knife
and there was a knife found on the
ground look at the footage he plays the
footage
and there's no knife in the footage
that's kind of weird isn't it and the
footage the girl's about to stab the
other girl but then
the knife is out of frame the frame is
paused
and the audio continues and you hear the
gunshots and falling to the ground
an absolute lie that they put on nbc
news
uh we should not do that that's a very
wrong thing but if nbc if lester hall
came out there and he said hey
i'm a leftist and i hate police
use of force even when it's justified
and so yeah this was a complicated case
but still he shouldn't have done it
okay that's fine at least i know what
i'm getting then and what i think we
like to do in conservative media is say
hey if you come in here i've got a
certain set of premises
i have a vision of the world i believe
these are the virtues and these are the
vices
and take it you know take it for what
it's worth
uh that's what i would do and i think
that's very respectable and i think it's
very just
and it's the only way forward um but but
i would not be reticent about telling
people what you think i would actually
to
the contrary i would encourage you to
tell people what you think and i hope
that you persuade them because
the left is telling everybody what to
think and they're totally wrong and
they've ruined the country
so if we have a smart young woman like
you who can tell people the truth
then i i don't want you to muzzle
yourself whether it be with one of those
fouchy masks or whether it be just in
general you know i
i want you to be able to to state your
views and persuade other people and i
i don't think that we should be tying
our hands behind our backs thank you
hi my name is elisa farino and i go to
trinity school at meadowview
and thank you so much for your talk but
i was wondering what you would suggest
that we as
young americans begin to help fix the
morality and the moral situation
of this country because as you're
talking about so many of the vices and
problems and problematic decisions
uh and just ideologies that are
happening now are because there is
skewed or
practically non-existent morality but
how should we begin to fix that and
bring the country back to more christian
values and just being a virtuous nation
great question it's not that there is no
morality in the country
it's not that there is no moral
education there is an anti-moral
education
it's not that educators and and people
of influence in the media
say hey that's kind of there's there's
nothing this is we're in this totally
neutral world
what they're saying is it is actively
good to engage in this kind of
behavior it's actively good to give in
to this disorder
desire it's actively good to follow this
inordinate passion
right and it's act and it's actively bad
to repress
those things can you the way we talk
about repression now
it's just though repression is the worst
thing repression is one of the greatest
inventions ever of civilization
is very good to repress your bad desires
imagine if you didn't repress all those
bad things you want to do
imagine how much crazier the country
would be well i know it would look like
the riots in the streets that we've seen
for the last year so
i think that what we need to do this is
similar i suppose to the previous
question
is we need to recognize the game we do
not live
in a neutral society of secular
liberalism where the left and right duke
it out on
equal fields and we're both restrained
we're not we're playing on the left's
battlefield that is the dominant regime
that is the dominant moral order that
we're living in
it is wrong we should subvert it every
chance we get
in a just manner i'm not saying we
should we should behave immorally
ourselves
because the ends justify the means but
we need to be
deeply outspoken and we need to be
effective
it's not enough to lose with dignity oh
my goodness how many conservatives
seem so determined to lose with dignity
one i don't i don't think they're
particularly dignified when they're
losing with dignity
but you know what's better than losing
with dignity
winning winning is better and so it
begins in this personal level you gotta
you gotta get your own house in order i
sound like i'm jordan peterson you've
got to eat the lobsters and get your own
house or order
yeah but you do he makes a good point
there's a reason he's so popular you
need to get your own house in order but
that is not enough and
i've seen the the doctrine of andrew
breitbart abused
you know the breitbart doctrine it's
perfectly true in itself politics is
downstream of culture what does that
mean it means that culture influences
politics well politics influences
culture too
give you an example of this east germany
today is mostly atheist i think it's 10
10 religious identification in east
germany west germany it's greater than
50
religious identification why is that
is it because of some cultural
difference in the type of bratwurst
between the east and the west no i might
have something to do with the
officially atheistic communist regime
dominating east germany for the entire
cold war
well the berlin wall fell guess what the
political
or rather the cultural effects of that
political order
are still being felt today it will take
who knows how long to to re-evangelize
east germany
so we need to say yes get our house in
order but then engage in the public
space the political space
and effect our views we are already
being coerced from the wrong side of
things
toward the evil and the ugly and the
falls
and we need to be willing to embrace and
effect and
push a politics of the good the true
and the beautiful thank you thank you
very much thank you all so much
so great to be with all of you as always
and maybe i don't know i've already been
to one of your campuses very recently
maybe i'll go to the other ones
soon as well thank you so much again
thank you
you